um okay um welcome back to the second
part of
today's program uh we will have one more
talk and then the discussion session
uh let's welcome the next speaker alec
ago from microsoft research
uh thanks leonga and uh well since we
can't be in berkeley physically i
decided i'll at least use a berkeley
background
uh if you can see my video um so uh yeah
today i'm gonna be talking about some
ideas uh for combining exploration with
policy gradient methods
and this is uh joint work with
uh sean kakare uh michael hanaf and
when vinson when michael and were
postdocs in microsoft
um you know uh well with this audience
we can get right into it uh this this
talk is about policy-grading methods
which
obviously uh are being quite uh heavily
used
uh empirically uh for a variety of
reasons
uh they're you know obviously optimizing
the quantity of interest
can be pretty flexible in handling
continuous and discrete states and
actions
uh different policy parameterization as
long as things are differentiable
and complementing this
empirical interest there's also been a
growing body
of theory to explain their convergence
properties
uh when do these methods probably find a
good uh
stationary point global optimum things
like that including
uh some work i actually presented at
simon's uh just last
uh last summer uh and if i had to
uh summarize uh you know this fairly
broad
uh set of works at this point starting
from you know really kind of the
the the cpi uh style analysis
um in in one sentence i would say
uh if you start a policy gradient method
if the initial state
in which you start a policy grading
method is uh sufficiently exploratory
um so you're basically not starting in a
in a particular initial state but it uh
sufficiently uh
diverse distribution over initial states
then you can
often hope to find a global optimum as
long as you have a reasonably rich
representation
and this is again not just a figment of
theory we also see this
this mirrored in practice when people
are doing things like domain
randomization
or intentional perturbations of the
initial state
to effectively ensure conditions like
this
and that's great but that also feels a
bit unsatisfactory to
kind of have to assume this property and
demand it from
um from the uh from the
people who are realizing the
implementation of the algorithm as
opposed to
somehow uh building in this
exploratory initial state property into
the algorithm itself
or to algorithmically um
obtain such initial distributions
uh which are suitably exploratory and
that's gonna that's the focus of this
work i'm talking about today
okay so just uh for standardizing uh
notation and such i'll do a very quick
overview of policy gradient methods
although this is probably familiar to
most of you
uh then talk about the algorithm and
its empirical evaluation okay so we're
going to be in the discounted mdp
uh setting uh for
the initial part of the theory i will
concretely make of
an assumption on the mdp dynamics which
is
uh the so-called linear mdp assumption
so the transition probability
s prime given sa factorizes as some
features
phi of s a uh inner product with uh some
function mu of s prime
and as is standard in some of these
works uh
this was first introduced by chijin and
co-authors in this form when the
features fee are known
and mu is uh unknown
and in particular uh mu doesn't have any
nice parametric form
um and
in contrast with some of the previous
works we will also allow fee to be
infinite dimensional so that
it can live in a reproducing kernel
hilbert space
the policy class which is pretty natural
when your mdp has this structure
is to consider these log linear policies
uh where you take the softmax of a
linear function
in the same feature space since the
features are known
and so the first part of the talk will
be uh primarily about
um you know what happens when we run
some policy grading methods
uh for this policy class in linear mdps
what are the convergence properties and
then we'll abstract away and talk about
motion
results usual
uh goal is to find a policy that gets a
large value in the initial state
and because we're interested really in
the exploration
question we don't want to kind of have
this confusion with
a good versus bad initial state
distribution i'm just going to
not require a distribution not have a
distribution over initial states at all
it's just some point mass
over a fixed initial state just just for
clarity purposes
okay so the particular style of policy
gradient
method we'll think about today is uh
related to natural policy gradient
uh from sham's phd work
um just for this one slide uh and for
stating some theoretical properties of
npg i will actually talk about a
distribution
row over states but that's
just for kind of the background material
okay so npt is a precondition first
order
method which is doing a
gradient ascent over the value function
in the parameter space
uh but rather than going in the raw
gradient interaction it
basically does preconditioning with the
pseudo inverse of
a fischer information matrix and
just for the case of log linear policies
um you can simplify the algorithm down
to this form instead which is the form
we'll talk about mostly
so this is a soft policy iteration right
which where we are
multiplicatively uh shifting
uh the policy pi t to get pi d plus one
um in using this direction wt
and what wt is if you took the q
function of the policy pi t
um and tried to do a linear
approximation of it
um so predict it using a linear function
w dot phi
then what's the best linear
approximation uh
when you do regression under the
distribution uh again induced by
the policy pi t starting from row okay
so that's that's quite that's quite a
bit let's let's let's pause
there for a moment um uh the way
the way this soft policy iteration is
happening is
we we we have some samples drawn from
executing pi t starting with rho
and on those samples we try to predict
the q values of pi
using a linear function and w is the
best linear approximation we get
and that provides the update direction
for the soft policy iteration
and uh qualitatively uh
again this is a bit informal but
qualitatively what we can
uh show is um npg will find the best
linear
log linear policy if the underlying
dynamics do satisfy the linear mdp
assumption
approximately and this is the second one
is basically this exploration condition
that the initial distribution row if you
look at the feature covariance matrix in
the fee features this is a well
conditioned matrix
okay so this is basically saying that
row provides you sufficient exploration
in the feature space
we also know for that for this algorithm
to succeed some condition on exploration
is unavoidable because otherwise we can
write these cnmdp type examples
where you the algorithm will have
vanishingly small
uh signal and will uh be able to do
nothing with finite samples so there
will be the usual exponential in horizon
so it's not that you know uh this this
is just a superfluous
uh condition the the part about having
well conditioning
and uh now with this more specific
context we can ask
well is there something we can do
algorithmically
to satisfy the second assumption about a
well-conditioned covariance
by actively exploring in the environment
okay um so that brings me to the pcpg
algorithm
uh i'll first give an intuitive uh kind
of high level description of the
algorithm
before going to uh more going through
more concrete
details so the basic uh
construct we use in pcpg uh so pcpg
stands for policy cover policy gradients
and the policy gradient part i've
already talked about policy cover is the
second crucial construct we use in the
algorithm
which is basically a collection of
exploratory policies that the algorithm
builds over time
and at any given point it has a
collection of these policies
and the initial distribution that it
constructs
is a uniform mixture of these
exploratory policies so
every time the agent needs to perform
uh an episode in the environment it will
pick one of these policies uniformly at
random
execute a random number of steps with
that policy
uh to get and get a starting state from
which it actually starts to
execute its decision policy
um now the key question there is
how do we obtain these policies for the
policy cover
and this is uh very much uh based on
the objective we had uh from the
theoretical understanding of
npg which is we want to obtain a
well-conditioned covariance matrix
under this initial distribution so we're
trying to seek out
we're trying to make sure that we visit
our our exploration policy visits all
possible directions
and so for the directions in the fee
space which are already visited
sufficiently often
and there's some threshold for that we
will define those things
as kind of known directions
and any direction which is not already
known
we will give some exploration bonus
to those directions to to visiting those
directions
and that will basically define a new
reward function
or a new bonus function and then we will
try to find a policy maximizing this
bonus
plus the original environment reward v
inpg
and we will add this resulting policy to
the cover and repeat this whole process
and this will keep repeating until we
cannot really find
um till till basically the bonus goes
away
okay so a bit more concretely
so we you know have some initial policy
and it's a
covariance matrix estimate and
as i said before uh at each um
kind of so it's sort of a two loop
algorithm at each outer loop or epoch
uh we construct an initial state
distribution
which is uniform over the policies in
the cover so far
and we also maintain an estimate of the
of the covariance of the mixture of
these policies which is just the
sum of their covariances
uh now the norm said um that the set of
directions where we have
sufficient visitation is defined
according to the formula
shown here so we ask
uh which are the directions uh
that have a small quadratic form in the
inverse covariance
of the current policy cover
the intuition is that if you already
visit a direction with a
with some significant probability that
direction will have
a large component in the covariance
matrix and hence a small
quadratic form with the inverse
covariance matrix for people who've seen
linear bandits before this is uh
certainly very reminiscent of
what gaussian goes on in there
and given this definition of known
states we simply set a bonus function
which provides something like an r max
bonus on
all the directions outside this known
set
and uh finally once we've defined this
bonus function we run
npg using this initial state
distribution rho i
and using the bonus augmented reward
function
okay so this way we are basically
constructing a sequence
of um increasingly exploratory initial
state distribution
uh with the idea that at some point you
know we will hopefully
hit the full coverage assumption and
then the
previous npg guarantee will just tell us
that we succeed
and indeed we can show that so for
linear
mdps we can show that
the oh sorry this is a stale name of the
algorithm
not r max pg pcpg so pcpg uses
samples which are polynomial in the
intrinsic dimension the intrinsic
dimension is important here because
we we allow ourselves to be an infinite
dimensional rkhs
uh but you can just think of it as the
raw dimension if you're in a finite
dimensional space
in one over epsilon in the horizon um
and uh all other relevant quantities and
outputs
are near optimal policy um
so um as with everything where you know
you say something is polynomial it
actually means
the actual dependence is uh somewhat
uh somewhat bad and that's certainly the
case for the existing theory although
over the summer
uh uh andrea zane who was my intern has
done some amazing improvements to the
sample complexity so it's uh
it's a lot nicer now um
we'll hopefully put that work out soon
let's talk about what happens outside a
linear mdp
so what is happening really with the
linear mdp is it's
giving us this very nice property that
first of all all policies have linear
value functions and all
bellman backups are linear
when we are not in a linear mdp we end
up requiring
an approximate expressivity condition
about the features still
and the precise condition you end up
needing is
that for all the policies you encounter
their q functions are well approximable
uh using linear functions okay that's
that's sort of
something you might expect to require
now the the interesting uh thing to note
is that the state action distribution
under which you
need to have a good fit here is not the
state action distribution of the policy
pi t but that of pi star
which is the optimal policy or whatever
policy you want to compare to really
okay so this is not this is kind of uh
this uh issue of uh you know
distribution mismatch we encountered
even in
uh batch policy optimization settings
and that's
[Music]
also cropping up here but if
this expressivity assumption is met with
some
quantity epsilon bias then you can state
basically a very similar result
completely divided the linear vp
assumption
with where we pay an additional
personality based on the epsilon bias
now we can ask when is this assumption
met
uh so so we're gonna fit some q values
under the
state action distribution of uh the
policy pi t
we're then gonna evaluate the fit under
pi star when can i be sure
that this fit remains good
well certainly for tabular and linear
mdps this this is assured
uh in the paper we also show a couple of
other examples uh we have one pretty
interesting result for state aggregation
where we can aggregate states under a
significantly milder metric than an l
infinity
type requirement on their transitions
and rewards coinciding
and there is also this uh very
interesting example structure of
partially linear mdps that props up
where
uh if your mdp has one subpart which is
which looks like a linear mdp and then
has other parts which are you know a
complete mess might even be a search
tree or whatever
and you've got a policy that basically
stays in the linear part and gets a
reasonable reward
then under some conditions you can learn
to compete with kind of the best search
policy
and i think that's a very interesting
structural characterization
uh so can we can we um
adapt these ideas to work beyond linear
settings when we don't have good
features in advance
uh empirically we definitely wanted to
investigate this question
and uh we we kind of uh
approached it by looking at a
random network distillation which in
which has a lot of similarities
uh with the with the style of um you
know
bonus bonus augmented policy gradient
that we are doing here with
two key differences so the r d bonus
obviously is
derived in a different manner then based
on the prediction loss
of a random network embedding of next
state then the bonus function we use
here
but i think uh the bigger actually
qualitative difference
is um that we are while we are
maintaining this exploratory policy
cover
rnd doesn't have such a counterpart and
we'll see
this second aspect is particularly
helpful with
catastrophic forgetting type issues
empirically
so the way we use um
our algorithm in empirical settings is
uh well we we simply use ppo as the base
algorithm instead of npg
and while we are using neural networks
for the policy
uh we design bonus functions using uh
just a separate set of features uh
obtained by by just running random
fourier features
um we do have some of the experiments
where we also do
random fourier features for both the
policy and the bonus and they also
that that also does seem to work
reasonably well in the
domains that we tried uh which are
one is this bi-directional combination
lock which is kind of a
worst case instance um uh if you will
that encodes both forgetting issues and
exploration issues
and then mountain car and uh well one
thing that's often not easy with policy
grading methods is to
adapt them to reward free settings
because this is an exploratory policy
gradient method
it actually does work in reward free
settings as well and that's the third
third experiment i'll talk about which
is reward for exploration and mazes
okay
yeah i have just one after this okay
thanks yeah almost done yeah uh so
uh you know in a nutshell algorithm
works quite well
uh generally outperforms uh uh rnd as
well as
raw ppo in all the experiments i think
the combination lock one is particularly
curious because it's bi-directional
um rnd literally succeeds
it's only about half the time once you
make the
the the problem long enough because
there is kind of two corridors
bifurcating at the initial state and it
um quickly learns to kind of always
explore like one
one hallway or the other um and this is
exactly the
forgetting effect we can overcome using
the policy covered in pcpg
and we do also uh perform quite well in
the reward free exploration settings
okay so um that that's kind of uh that's
kind of it uh
you know there is some important uh
directions
that we wanted to think about uh going
forward one is of course where do these
features come from
can we learn them design them and uh
well you just have to wait for the next
workshop where uh akshay will
uh talk about some exciting results uh
in that direction
um i already mentioned that we've
managed to
obtain some important improvements in
sample complexity
uh i think one thing that uh you know uh
already kind of
uh also we've we've been having some
discussions um
in the simon's discord channel with
gergie like one of the things that be
pretty
uh fun to think about is uh sharper
characterizations
of what are what what's the set of
situations
under which this expressivity assumption
can be met
which might also help us think about how
to further improve upon it
that's the link to the paper if you're
curious and
yeah happy to answer questions
yeah thanks alec uh this is really
interesting we have a few minutes for uh
questions hey hey alec
uh just a quick question i i think i i
sort of missed the part where
you know for the linear function
approximation setting we use the
covariance matrix to measure like known
versus unknown
uh and explore versus non-export uh
what is this adapted version for the
more general function transformation
setting
oh um so no the policy class
we use um is always going to be log
linear
at least in the theory where we relax
is on the linear mdp side so we are not
necessarily going to assume that the mdp
dynamics are linear in those features
uh but only instead require expressivity
conditions in terms of the value
function yeah no no i i get that part
i get that part where you still have
linear function transformation but the
underlying ndp
is no longer linear mvp but but i
thought you have further experiments
oh right right so there what we were
doing uh was
okay so you can do it in two different
ways right so one is you can say well
okay
if uh i'm using a neural network then i
will use whatever the current
featurization that
the network has learned in order to
introduce features uh we were
a bit worried that that might be too
unstable so what we did was we just kind
of completely decoupled the bonus
and the policy and we said we'll just
use random fourier features to
induce the bonus function while the
policy is a neural network
and so that that's a you know that's not
necessarily the most satisfying thing
so the so the former solution you're
talking about is essentially this like
you have your parent urine and you treat
the everything except for the last layer
as
fixed and then you get something linear
you should got it yeah yeah
yeah we do currently need to linearize
things somehow for the bonus
i have a question regarding um the
exploration dynamics if i understand
correctly
the uh the bonus is an indicator
function as to whether
whether you've explored something uh
enough or not and then so in model-based
exploration that sort of makes sense
that you know rmax style
after a while you stop and you're gonna
go but but what i'm surprised here is
this is
in some sense model free right there's
no explicit replanning
you would just update the parameters of
the policy what do the dynamics look
like
well so i i guess i think of this
algorithm as
kind of in between model based and model
free
because really i think what the policy
cover
gives you is a representation of the
dynamics
in your policy space so in some ways it
is very much like a
like if you run it in a tabular setting
what you will get out of this algorithm
is one policy for each state action pair
uh such that the policy has a good
probability of visiting that state
action pair
and now is that model free or not model
based i
you know leave that up for debate i i
think but i think it's very much model
based in certain sense
um and what the other thing to point out
by the way
for the i i believe for the experimental
plots i've shown here
uh we eventually decided to just use the
quadratic form as the bonus instead of
the indicator as the bonus so
the there is the indicator of a
quadratic form being large
uh is just replaced by the quadratic
form itself
i like this is super interesting one
question i just had it was that it
seemed if i understand correctly one
sort of giving a bonus to
parts of the state action space which
you have visited once or a small number
of times but don't have a really
accurate estimate of
but one thing i would be curious about
is it still seems like that sort of
grows out the state action space
sort of um from the edges outwards but
one thing that we know is challenging
for
from tabular cases is that if you don't
like if you've never reached the end of
the chain which is really good then you
can't know that you should put a bonus
there
um so i was curious if this if there are
some limitations to this
if you don't know the full state in
action space or or how it works in that
setting
so uh yeah i guess um
you know uh maybe the assumption that's
being made
is once you give me some features i'll
basically think of something like
so let's say whatever i'll think of the
unit ball
in that feature space um as the entire
space of state action pairs now it could
be that a bunch of those directions are
actually not reachable
by anything um and
that's totally fine so what what at some
point you'll basically find that yes i
i i still have this bonus function but
there is
uh no policy that can get a large reward
under the bonus and at that point the
algorithm
would have terminated anyways so
you know i i guess what the algorithm
does need to have is
uh through this feature space um
at least uh a superset of all possible
states and actions
uh if you if i guess i don't know how to
think about not knowing states and
actions
because once i once i say that i have
the features then
it's um yeah it just uh doesn't make
sense anymore
well i guess even for the chain example
i just mentioned i guess you'd sort of
slowly grow it out
like you'd slowly you'd not strip a
bonus for the first part of the chain
and then you'd explore part of that and
then there'd be a bonus if you hadn't
seen some of those states and actions
yet and you're in the distribution
you're optimizing over so that's right
right you can kind of i guess you can
always keep believing that there's going
to be another state to the right in that
chain example and at some point well
you'll
not be able to go right anymore and
you'll you'll you'll know
yeah cool cool um so maybe you can
have a couple of quick questions from
the
audience uh alec can you see the
questions uh yeah yeah yeah
yes um okay so uh
the does the policy cover have some
interesting properties
uh yes it it has many interesting
properties so it does
indeed try to
it basically tries to give you um like
in the linear mdp setting it really is
trying to
uh get you to uh you can think a
spherical covariance matrix and it
and once you reach the point that uh you
have a good mass
in all directions in the coherence
matrix of the policy cover
or emotionally no policy can excite a
direction
in which the the covariance doesn't have
mass
the algorithm stops uh exploring
um the uh one one over minus gamma
reward on unseen states and actions
works because
um like if you think about uh
like that's the largest possible reward
you can get in the mdp right so
if uh you knew nothing about a state and
if it turns out that you had a
you know rewarding self loop there
that's the largest possible reward you
can hope to get from there
and so it just makes um it guarantees
that
um you know policy going to an unknown
state is always going to be more
preferable
to policy staying within known parts
it's just kind of
making things provably optimistic small
correction you said reward you meant
value
yes thank you
do we need to use covering number
argument like genital no um
one of the one of the reasons we use the
indicator rather than the quadratic form
uh but also because uh we are not really
um like we we never have to
learn the value functions of all
possible policies in the same
like the particular you i i think you're
asking about the uniform
conversions argument which ends up being
a bit problematic
uh in some prior works and we
we don't need the analog of that just
because
the structure of the pg analysis is a
bit different
okay awesome um yes there's a lot of
questions maybe
some of these can wait until the
discussion session that is coming up
next
um